foreign
[Music]
polling people concerned about age how
does the president plan to convince the
American people over the next year that
80 is not too old for someone who's
running for re-election 80's to new 40.
did you hear
um
yo yo it's Monday September 18th 2023
I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report
we are live streaming on Rumble YouTube
and locals share tap that notification
Bell so you have at least a slim chance
of seeing our videos uh we've got a post
game wrap up at reubenreport.locals.com
as always and uh a bit of a personal
note before we do Today's Show before I
give you the full rundown on what we're
doing today uh you know usually when I
wake up in the morning and we're ready
to put together a show and Phoenix and I
are texting back and forth on how we
want to craft the show today and what
the arc is going to look like and the
story that we're going to tell you
um you know we're going through current
events oh this person said that some
lunatic on The View said this MSNBC
Trump Biden uh uh today's show is going
to be focused around uh what's going on
with Russell Brand I I consider Russell
Brand a friend we've only met in person
I think really just the one time that I
had him in studio in Miami uh just what
was that four or five months ago
obviously we've chatted a bunch of other
times uh I helped him get on board with
Rumble and locals and all that kind of
stuff and the Machine is really going
after him right now it is my hope that
although I'm gonna cover it today that
enough of you will know the games of the
machine because we've talked about this
for so long the smoke screen and the
confusion that the machine throws at
everybody where they try to make it seem
like the good guys are the bad guys and
the bad guys are the good guys and
everything else so I kind of didn't want
to discuss this at all because these
allegations against Russell
my guess are complete nonsense or at
least within the within the historical
context of them happening probably have
no real value but what this is really
about I just have no doubt even if he at
one point did something that he
shouldn't have done what this is about
more than anything else is that if you
tell the truth they will come after you
and that is that is a very scary premise
uh I like to believe that I'm one of the
people that's telling you the truth and
it's like they come after everybody so
we are going to cover it I hope we never
have to cover it again I kind of want to
just address it once so we can just put
it to bed and then we'll watch the
people that lie about everything
continue to lie about it but I thought
it was important just to say that at the
beginning because I I don't want this
story of a guy who I think has done some
really good stuff we talk about him
quite often on this show uh some really
good stuff over the last couple of years
and has had a really interesting
political Evolution and who has called
out the people who deserve to be called
out well now the machines coming to hit
him and I don't want to feed that
monster I simply do not want to do it so
yes the the theme of the show jumping
off with Russell is how the mainstream
media treats their opponents versus how
they treat their lackeys and hint uh yes
it is very very different but it does
seem that some people
who kind of get it sometimes say a Bill
Maher or even a Donald Trump uh they
kind of get it sometimes and they rail
Against the Machine they always go back
to salvating over the machine when push
comes to shove so that is the theme for
today's show before we get to it let's
talk about moink box and then we'll dive
deep on all of that uh you guys know
that 60 of U.S pork production comes
from one company owned by the Chinese
and their Hogs are given something
called ractopamine which is banned in
160 countries including China yet you
find it in your grocery aisle every day
guys there's a better way which is why I
want to tell you about Mike you know it
is Moo plus oink Mike delivers grass-fed
and grass-finished beef and lamb
pastured pork and chicken and
sustainable wild caught Alaskan salmon
straight to your door boink Farmers Farm
like our grandparents did and as a
result moink meat tastes like it should
because the Family Farm just does it
better the moink difference is a
difference you can taste and you can
feel good knowing you're helping Family
Farms stay financially independent as
well you choose the meat it delivered in
every box like rib eyes to chicken
breasts to pork chops to salmon fillets
and much more plus you can cancel any
time Shark Tank host Kevin O'Leary
called moink's bacon the best bacon he's
ever tasted and you know that they say
you'll they say you'll say oink oink I'm
just so happy I got moyed keep American
farming going by signing it at
moinkbox.com Reuben right now at
listeners of this show get free ground
beef for a year that's one of the best
ground beef you'll ever taste but for a
limited time Moi and kbox.com
rubenmoitfox.com Reuben and now back to
me okay so look Russell Brand is under
attack from the machine the London times
has been working on an expose against
him for a long time now and he got some
early Advance warning that it was coming
out Russell did the right thing was
which was address it right out of the
gate here is a portion of that and then
that'll kind of set up the rest of today
show
hello there you Awakening wonders now
this isn't the usual type of video we
make on this channel where we critique
attack and undermine the news in all its
corruption because in this story I am
the news I've received two extremely
disturbing letters or a letter and an
email one from a mainstream media TV
company one from a newspaper listing a
Litany of extremely egregious and
aggressive attacks as well as some
pretty stupid stuff like uh my community
Festival should be stopped that I
shouldn't be able to attack mainstream
media narratives on this channel but
amidst this Litany of astonishing rather
bar Rock attacks are some very serious
allegations that I absolutely refute
these allegations pertain to the time
when I was working in the mainstream
when I was in the newspapers all the
time when I was in the movies and as
I've written about extensively in my
books I was very very promiscuous now
during that time of promiscuity the
relationships I had were absolutely
always consensual I was always
transparent about that then almost too
transparent and I'm being transparent
about it now as well and to see that
transparency metastasized into something
criminal that I absolutely deny makes me
question is there another agenda at play
particularly when we've seen coordinated
media attacks before like with Joe Rogan
when he dared to take a medicine that
the mainstream media didn't approve of
and we saw a Spate of headlines from
media Outlets across the world using the
same language I'm aware that you guys
have been saying in the comments for a
while watch out Russell they're coming
for you you're getting too close to the
truth Russell Brad did not kill himself
it's been clear to me or at least it
feels to me like there's a serious and
concerted agenda to control these kind
of spaces and these kind of voices and I
mean my voice along with your voice also
it's worth mentioning that there are
witnesses whose evidence directly
contradicts the narratives that these
two mainstream media Outlets are trying
to construct apparently in what seems to
me to be a coordinated attack
there's a lot to unpack here and as I
said this gives me no pleasure and my
hope is and my intention is that after
today I will not address this story
again because what I'm trying to do by
addressing it today uh is I don't want
more attention on this nonsense and what
the London Times is trying to do to
Russell Brand I want enough of you
hopefully to understand the way the
Machine Works he's laying it out there
quite quite clearly and then if we don't
give it the attention if we don't give
it the clicks and the coverage that it
wants although I'll show you the type of
coverage that it's getting right now
that maybe it will kind of go away
Russell for many years has been very
actually outspoken about some of his
previous behaviors of being promiscuous
and banging a lot of chicks and going
out to clubs he's written about it he's
talked about it on podcasts he's now
happily married he just had I think his
second child about two months ago
he has changed I want to know if any of
you watching this right now were you
different in your 20s did you have a lot
of sex or do a lot of drugs or whatever
it might be he is making it very very
clear he did not rape anyone or assault
anyone or anything like that but again
that's all a sideshow that's all a
sideshow because there's only one reason
that they're doing this with him if
Russell Brand was still the same Russell
Brand of seven years ago who was in a
couple movies and doing some stand-up
specials about whatever it might be
they'd never be gone after I don't even
know that I what movies was he in I
don't even know that I've got Him to the
Greek never saw it what other stuff was
he in I never really knew of Russell
Brand I knew he was a British kind of
over-the-top comedian uh years ago he
evolved into something else but my point
is if he was still
the Russell Brand of seven years ago
they would never be going after him
right but now I want to show you what
this is really about what this is really
about and obviously I don't have every
insight into every little thing he did
okay or didn't do but the point is the
fact that I even have to say that
already shows you how they start making
you look at people who don't deserve to
be looked at so you don't look at the
actual people who should be looked at
right we've seen this again and again
whether it was Joe Rogan during covid
right whether it was Jordan Peterson
from page of the New York Times uh that
Jordan Peterson was for enforced
monogamy which made it sound like he
wanted women to be in the handmaid's
tale whether it was the front page of
the New York Times when they put me and
Ben Shapiro and Thomas Saul and Milton
Friedman as the leaders of the alt-right
I mean they've done this time and again
and the point of discussing it is so
that you don't fall for it again but
look what they are doing this is from
Ian miles Chung on Twitter he found this
video of just what the front page of the
papers in England look right now look
like right now and it's a ballot or that
he raped me and all of this stuff it
hidden Plain Sight like he is now the
enemy of the people and there is nothing
worse for as bad as our mainstream media
is there is almost nothing worse than a
British tabloid if you want to know a
bit about that I would recommend you
watch the crown on Netflix and see what
they did I mean it's just to Diana and
the rest of it that's a little bit of a
sidebar but they've been doing this
forever and if Russell was not always
attacking mainstream they would not be
putting him all over the covers by the
way he also addressed this uh when they
put this together this this attack piece
on him on what he's done several girls
then reached put out public videos
saying that they reached out to me but
because I said he treated me with
respect that it was totally consensual
and everything else they decided not to
include them in the Articles this is
what they do with everything with
everything absolutely everything guys so
again why are they looking at Russell
Brand do you think it might be because
he's been looking at them
I have respect for you in your show I've
bought some facts would you
[Applause]
I wouldn't have mentioned it I'm English
and you know that politeness is our
fundamental religion but they do pertain
to this issue so may I say something
please say inconvenience you I'll stop
saying them the pandemic created at
least 40 new far big Pharma billionaires
pharmaceutical corporations like moderna
and Pfizer made a thousand dollars of
profit every second from the covid-19
vaccine more than two-thirds of Congress
received campaign funding from
pharmaceutical companies in the 2020
election Pfizer chairman Albert baller
told Time magazine in July 2020 that his
company was developing a covered vaccine
for the good of humanity not for money
and of course Pfizer made a hundred
million dollars in profit in 2022. and
may I just mentioned that finally and
these are this is also a fact that you
the American public funded the
development of that the German Republic
funded the bio and Tech vaccine when it
came to the profits they took the
profits when it came into the funding
you paid for the funding all I'm
querying is this yes is if you have an
economic system in which pharmaceutical
companies benefit hugely from medical
emergencies where a military industrial
complex benefits from war where an
energy companies benefit from energy
crisis you are going to generate states
of Perpetual crisis so the interests of
Ordinary People yes and separate from
the interests of the allegiance
I did very bizarre that they're going
after Russell Brand right now with
allegations from a decade ago and
ignoring people who go against those
allegations do you think it's weird do
you think it is something to do with
some of this now what's interesting is
it does seem to me and again why I'm
really trying going to do my best not to
cover this going forward after today uh
that it doesn't seem to be latching on
the way it has we've been living through
the last what five years of cancel
culture and random people being
destroyed and oh that comedian said that
seven years ago and everything else and
we watched Roseanne Barr who had the
number one sitcom In America get
canceled uh for a joke like it's all so
stupid and ridiculous and we've also
seen it at this point we've looked
behind that curtain and seen that it's
just a little man there and not the
all-powerful Oz that it does seem like
perhaps this is the one that isn't quite
going to work now I always Grant the
machine
you know the the credit that it deserves
and that it's always a step ahead so who
knows but Elon Musk has come out in
support of Russell Brand Jordan Peterson
has come out in in support of Russell
Brand Joe Rogan has come out in support
of Russell Brand the people kind of see
the difference in this one and and I
just hope more and more people will it
has way more to do with his beliefs and
what he's been doing for a living than
anything that he might have done in back
in his days and again every every single
one of us me every single one of you
watching this everyone regrets an affair
they had this that the other thing you
know what I mean like everyone made
mistakes in their life everyone was too
promiscuous everyone drank too much or
smoked too much or did whatever God
knows what they did right and if you
want to destroy everybody for their past
then no one will ever have a future it
is as simple as that now I want to throw
to a video of Russell in 2019 so this is
four years ago when he was just
beginning to question some of the stuff
that led him to becoming the Russell
Brand that we now know provide
alternative narratives and not only
provide the narratives invite you to
create the narratives with us because do
you know one thing I know I don't know
what's best I've made a lot of mistakes
I've been wrong many times but I'm
beginning to think I'm right about this
the mainstream media is not your friend
the culture is not your friend the
government is not your friend big
business is not your friend okay so that
was the beginning of his Evolution and
he went and went and went and went and
now how is the machine heading back just
like that week you all remember it at
the height of covid and everything else
when Joe Rogan was questioning all of
the things related to covet and why
can't we use regeneron and why do we
have to be vaxxed and then what happened
the machine out of nowhere for a week
everybody on CNN New York Times
Washington Post Joe Rogan's a racist
look at all the times he said the n-word
even though he never said the n-word to
to in a pejorative manner he never said
it to be racist he was mocking people
who use it that way but they've done
this time and again if I was to show you
how many mainstream hit pieces on me
Dave Rubin leader of the alt-right
racist Dave Rubin he platforms these
people he's dangerous and they do it to
try to scare the F out of you meaning me
and these types of people in this case
but it's really to scare the f you we
will continue with this theme after I
tell you about Patriots Supply uh do you
get the feeling that something's going
to happen bad is going to happen soon
that's a hell of a segue right there I
do but between the distractions and
smoke screens in the media we probably
won't see it coming that's why it's
smart to invest in emergency food right
now as they say it's better to have it
and not need it than to need it not have
it my Patriot supplies the nation's
leader in high quality emergency food
head over to my website prepare with
reuben.com you'll save 200 bucks on your
three-month emergency food kit from my
Patriot Supply enjoy a wide variety of
delicious meals offering over 2 000
calories every day for Optimum strength
under stress stock up before Panic sets
in free shipping is automatic and your
order ships fast go to prepare with
reuben.com prepare with reuben.com and
now back to me okay so the other
story of the last couple days and we're
going to link all of this and bring it
around to Russell at the end was that
Lauren bobert congresswoman Lauren
bobert who I've had on the show I
enjoyed spending time with her I think
she's been a good Fighter for
conservative principals she went to
Beetlejuice the musical and someone
squeezed her boob and well here's the
headline from Politico on that one
bobert caught on video apologizes for
inappropriate behavior at Beetlejuice
show okay so we're not going to show you
but somehow using like video that you
can see in the dark she went on a date
she's in the middle of a divorce she
went on a date with this guy she also
Vaped in the theater I guess you're not
allowed to Vape in the theater so she
Vaped the guy grabbed her boob looks
like she kind of grabbed his crotch this
was done in the dark I'm not defending
any of it but can we put that headline
up again I just want to show you that
this is the point here's the political
headline on what she did and again she
got her people like sweet put the camera
back on me for a second I'm here with
three heterosexual men
you all like squeezing a boob every now
and again right this is something you
enjoy Connor was like I do I do Phoenix
you like you like the boob you got no
problem Brock not into the boot Brock
doesn't care for the boob do we have to
tell your fiance to say that that's
gonna be a problem
anyway the point is all right she got
her boobs squeezed she grabbed his nuts
who cares
but look at the headline on this one
again now put the headline up bobert
caught on video apologizes for
inappropriate behavior at Beetlejuice
show now let's go to Politico just two
or three days earlier because you may
have heard this story there is a
Virginia state senator she's a Democrat
by the name of Susanna Gibson she was on
a website called
chatterbait.com don't go there right now
please especially if you're at work uh
and she was doing sex acts with her
husband okay I don't know if you know
this guys there's porn online people
watch it okay Zippity doodah but it got
exposed now it's not exposed it's not
even the right word she was doing this
publicly it was on a public website but
look at the headline on Politico so what
if the candidate live streamed sex acts
with their husband so when it's a
Democrat who cares if she's getting
banged by her husband and sticking a
lamp up or hoo-ha and everything else
that she's a Democrat who cares but if
Lauren bobert gets her boobs squeezed
and again I'm not even equivocating
these things or anything else what I'm
trying to show you
of course is the double standard of all
these things and by the way to some
extent there there should be a double
standard in that conservatives have some
set of principles and Democrats
generally don't have principles right so
if if Lauren
um you know if she puts herself up there
as a Christian conservative or whatever
it might be maybe she shouldn't be
getting her boobs squeezed and grabbing
the guy's nuts that's fine what I'm
trying to show you here is the way the
media if you're a republican it's
naughty and inappropriate and if you're
a Democrat and you're getting banged on
a webcam yes you should be a state
senator and if anyone calls you you know
you're a bad girl for that you should be
in a lot of trouble uh anyway on CNN
they covered it uh the bobert thing and
well they just laughed about it
well let me uh speaking of ushering let
me talk to both of you about Colorado uh
Congressman Lauren beaubridge she she
was booted from Beetlejuice uh that and
it's mostly because no one's grabbed
either one of their boobs in a long time
but they think it's hilarious that
someone's boob got grabbed it was less
funny to the people of CNN when Jeffrey
two bit came back after he was caught
masturbating on a zoom call
um in October you were on a zoom call
with your colleagues from The New Yorker
magazine everyone took a break for
several minutes during which time you
were caught masturbating on camera
uh you were subsequently fired from that
job after 27 years of working there and
you since then have been on leave from
CNN do I have all that right um You got
it all right sad to say Okay so let's
start there
um to quote Jay Leno what the hell were
you thinking well obviously I wasn't
thinking very well or very much and
um it was something that was
inexplicable to me I think one point I I
wouldn't exactly say in my defense
because nothing is really in my defense
I didn't think I was on the call I
didn't think other people could see me
you know what we should have done we
would have been demonetized but we
should have had the camera come back to
me and I should have been masturbating I
know it didn't no
well they all just handed in their
resignation right all three you were
like we've been waiting Dave we
um
you get the point guys people do these
things and then they frame it if you're
a good guy and a Democrat and a lefty
you get framed one way and we'll give
you the job back and everything else if
you're a republican we gotta cancel you
because you got your boob squeezed if
you're Russell Brand now they're trying
to also frame Russell random some crazy
right-wing Maniac Russell Brand who I'm
pretty sure is supporting Lefty lunatic
Cornell West for president who had Noam
Chomsky on a couple weeks ago who still
I think is uh let's say confused a
little bit about some of the political
issues of the day and by the way I
discussed that with him in my interview
anyway you see the double standard and
all that but now let's shift a little
bit because there is something
interesting happening in the media right
now related to the lies and how much the
system can control the lies at once so
ABC's John Carl went on uh the view so
we are going to show you a clip of the
view we actually have two clips of The
View no I think we have three clips of
Jesus we have three clips of The View
what am I doing with my life we have
three clips of you about eight the ABC's
John Carl went on The View now funny
thing about John Carl I don't this I'm
going to get the numbers off slightly
but when don't burn this book came out
uh we should have been number two on the
New York Times bestseller and the sales
numbers are very obvious because it's
sales so they can't fake it like the
sales numbers come through but then the
New York Times just re-jiggers their
list however they see fit Jonathan I
think I sold like 40 000 copies first
week you're saying John the girl sold
like four thousand copies I'm pretty
sure they put him at number four and
they put me at number 11. I only
mentioned that to say this is a guy
who's in it with the system he's the
machine he feeds the machine what it
wants and the Machine spits back you
know the stuff for him okay that's fine
anyway he went on The View talking about
Hunter Biden and Joe Biden corruption
and barisma and all that and they they
kind of make sense here this is weird
and this shows you that the system is
not impervious watch this this is going
to blow your mind like there's a even
Anna Navarro I'm leading too much just
watch
it has an appearance of in front as a
matter of fact this is a little piece of
personal trivia I believe I am the only
White House reporter who asked about
Hunter Biden and barisma during the
Obama administration because as soon as
that deal was announced that he was
going on the board of barisma he was
going to be paid about 50
000 a month I I went and I asked Jay
Carney who was then the White House
Press Secretary said this isn't you know
his father was the vice president and
he's in charge of Ukraine policy you
know isn't that at the very least
unseemly it may not be illegal but I
mean so so he said well you know this he
gave me basically a non-answer saying
that that the the vice president had
nothing to do with this yeah
um and that you know ponzer Biden's
going to do what Hunter Biden's gonna do
and it got and it got reviewed by the
state department didn't it yeah and
approved which I think it shouldn't have
I mean I mean look it you can say this
looks like what like sleazy it doesn't
look right but the question is is there
anything illegal and is there any
evidence whatsoever that Joe Biden
actually took part
okay I am telling you mark my words they
are getting rid of Joe Biden and the
fact that ABC News just put on one of
their main guys right to go on The View
to discuss that why else would you put
him on they're trying to show you that
something is there so that he will step
down again he's not going to be
impeached because they don't have the
Senate but they're trying to show him
the door otherwise it make why would you
bring on you have to understand these
are highly produced shows they pick when
they are going to have someone on and
exactly what they are going to say he
knows and the producers know what he's
going to say there so he says and uh
he's like look at me I was one of the
first guys to say that there was
something there was something going on
here in Jay Carney who was the Press
Secretary of the time he was the cringe
Jean-Pierre of his day he just kind of
blew it off but obviously something was
there and then even freaking Anna
Navarro when they're like oh they passed
it through the state department the
state department said it was fine
meaning that Hunter had this job and Joe
is the vice president and it made no
sense because he was a crack addict and
why should a crack addict be working at
a Ukrainian Energy company even Anna
Navarro's like that shouldn't have
happened so they're admitting the view
just platformed and a newsman to say
something's rotten in stink town and
then they agreed with it they agreed
with it
okay but now let's go back to the crazy
portion of the view because it's almost
like someone coming out of a coma for
just a second they came out of the coma
they were saying for a second now they
go into their coma stupor uh here's Anna
Navarro on guns
I was reading today uh he was one of the
kids who was in the car when a sibling
yeah
Joe Biden's first wife and child he was
traumatized by that he probably has a
lot of Survivor guilt and all that and
that has broken it he needs therapy well
his brother as one of the 80 percent of
Republicans who do support background
checks this is an example of background
checks working an addict should not be
able to get a gun and the fact I do
think that he I how he's you know what
the conviction ends up being that
remains to be seen I do think he should
be indicted on this I don't think you
should have addicts who are easily this
is the only time Republicans don't want
somebody to have a gun well that will
find out
all of a sudden this should be indicted
yet you have states where you can open
carry without even applying for it's the
only time Republicans don't want people
to have guns well you know we do have
the Second Amendment we're allowed to
have guns okay just to be clear
no state in the Union back check me on
this one Media Matters no state in the
Union has no background check there is a
federal background check then some
states have extra laws it's obviously
harder to get a gun in a place like
California and then you know what
happens in the cities in California
they're very violent because good people
have a harder time getting a gun
actually one of the one of the true like
oh my God does my does my politics did
my politics match my reality moments was
it at the height of kovid when we were
having the summer of love and they were
burning down LA and the rampaging
through the city and riots were
literally going by my house and people
knew where I lived and we decided Well
we got Clyde Emma had just passed away
our previous dog one thing if you get a
dog you know that if you get a dog you
have something like 90 percent less
chance of your house being broken into
because people just you know they case
your house and they they just don't want
to deal with the dog so we got Clyde
that was one thing although I mostly got
clyded because they were just killing
dogs in the name of covid because they
were gonna just kill they were literally
just going to kill them because they
didn't want people working at shelters
so I just grabbed him and saved him
anyway we got Clyde and then we got a
couple guns and and I cannot tell you if
I named them they would kill me the
amount of my liberal celebrity friends
in Hollywood who are asking me where I
got my guns and how they could get guns
so Alyssa fair is completely lying you
cannot be an addict and get a gun
without a without a background check yes
there's illegal ways to get guns but we
already have laws for these things so
again the view had a moment of sanity
and Clarity and then they go right back
to their lying and pandering and
nonsense but now just one more from The
View because uh this one just came out
of nowhere this is from Friday's View
and I just I was just like what in the
world is this and well take a look
disregard for people are you pregnant no
oh my God
thank you
you can't say that when my mother-in-law
is here he's the guide for me to get
pregnant why would you say that why do I
look pregnant yes I just gotta I did you
get the glow I got I just got out of my
tummy
I'm so sorry I'm so sorry
can we take this can we take beds at the
table
what is going on with these women I'm
pretty sure Whoopi's uh pregnant with
quintuplets but uh
people wake up and watch that program
it's on right now it's wild anyway I
don't know what the hell is going on
over there but the point is the point of
all of that really was the first clip
that that's something weird there's
there's something weird in The Ether
right now that the system is now
allowing people to acknowledge what a
whole bunch of us were acknowledging
four or five years ago right and the
system always figures out a way to stay
ahead so you know four years ago if you
were talking about the hunter Biden
laptop story you might have been banned
from Twitter uh if you tried to share it
in your DMs you know you got shut down
all of that stuff Facebook was
de-boosting it the mainstream media was
completely calling it a conspiracy
theory what was it 70 how many uh CIA
officials said it was misinformation was
it 52 what's the famous number remember
it was something like 52 former
three-letter agency people front page of
the New York Post say that the hunter
buying laptop is misinformation turns
out to all be true but you get it now
the system's kind of allowing people to
talk about it because they can't silence
everybody at once that's how it works
but there are agents of the machine and
one of the Agents of the machine is Jen
saki over at the televised mental
institution known as MSNBC and of course
she was a paid liar at the White House
and now she's just a more highly paid
liar over at MSNBC uh here she is
defending Hunter and Joe Biden we have
to have a rule of law Mika and Joe it's
such a relief to hear that from people
um including when it's about as you just
said somebody who is very close to the
president I mean first and foremost the
politics of this are a little hard to
predict but right now you have the
president's son somebody he loves deeply
somebody who has very publicly struggled
with drug addiction now facing these
charges which are serious and I'll let
Andrew do a contemplation of the
legality and the process and all of that
which I know a lot of us have questions
on what is tricky to watch here and what
I think we all will be watching is what
do Republicans do with this on the hill
as it relates to their impeachment
process baloney efforts right we didn't
see a lot of that yesterday a lot of the
tying of these charges to their
impeachment efforts if there are
additional charges that we see from the
Department of Justice that Andrew just
alluded to I suspect they would try to
do that but right now what we're looking
at and I think on the politics of this
you know millions of Americans have
dealt with family members who haven't
dealt with drug addiction who've dealt
with alcohol addiction who have dealt
with a range of addiction my bet is
right now this is a heartbroken
president in the White House who is
worried about his son and we're all
watching to see it's so incredible what
she's doing there instead of any of the
impropriety and where did all of these
millions of dollars magically appear in
various Biden family members accounts
and why did the crack addict have the
job at the Ukrainian Energy company and
why did Joe Biden threaten to fire the
prosecutor in Ukraine who was looking
into the whole freaking thing instead of
any of that this is about the love of
the Son and the drug addict and that
there are people who drink in America I
drink because of people like her that's
really what's going on here I these
people are such liars and think and what
does she call it the impeachment process
baloney efforts the impeachment process
bologna efforts do you know that they
impeached Donald Trump twice right they
went for this nonsense twice nobody even
remembers what it was about and if
anything they were trying to impeach him
for things that Joe Biden did in the
first place collusion etc etc et cetera
but speaking of baloney uh here's Adam's
ship and now this is another guy this is
a guy like fauci who has so been wrong
and lied about everything that he should
be in a cave somewhere I'm not saying we
should arrest him I think there's
probably reasons that you could or he at
least broke his oath of office to defend
the Constitution of the United States
and things of that nature but these are
people who should be shamed into
Oblivion and never put on these
television programs again but they
constantly get on the TV programs
because they give the system just what
it wants so here's Adam Schiff on the
televised mental institution known with
Nicole Wallace Nicole Wallace who of
course is she's a Democrat operative and
here they are talking about how this
impeachment is complete nonsense this is
the same guy who ran two other sham
impeachments let's get his feelings on
the impeachment of his guy
I want to ask you to contrast Mitch
McConnell's declaration that quote they
nailed him the impeachment managers of
Donald Trump with Republican house
members confession that there's zero
evidence linking President Joe Biden to
anything worthy of an impeachment what
do you make of the Sham we try not to
call it an impeachment inquiry but a
speakership clinging to by Kevin
McCarthy going on in the house
foreign
is such a contrast from the methodical
way we went about uh Gathering the
evidence and the first impeachment and
the seriousness with which we took the
responsibility of finding High crimes
and misdemeanors
um to what we see today which is
essentially an evidence-free impeachment
uh proceeding of some kind
guys they were so meticulous last time
under his name on the Chiron it should
say failed impeachment guy right like
why it should say why are we bringing
this guy back on to talk about anything
because he was so meticulous in all his
impeachment stuff that nothing came of
any of it right
nonsense nonsense nonsense well here's
another guy that the machine has tried
to destroy repeatedly uh Tucker Carlson
uh this is him calling out Schiff six
years ago 2017. watch this this is fun
you're you're on the
you're on the one final question can you
look right into the camera and say I
know for a fact the government of
Vladimir Putin was behind the hacks of
John podesta's absolutely the government
of Vladimir Putin was behind the hacks
of our institution and the dump of John
podesta not only in the Johnson's email
but also in Europe okay you're not you
know what you're document and Tucker I
know they did
I think that uh Ronald Reagan
you're carrying water for the Kremlin
you're a sitting number of Congress on
the inside body and you can't say they
you're gonna you're gonna have to move
your shoulder to RT Russian television
because you know what this is perfectly
if you're in office because it's so dumb
and you're being duplicitous I'm asking
you did they hack modesta's emails
like that Tucker
oh you set up getting water for Putin
that's pretty hilarious you know when
you when you is an apologist for the
criminal that's what you're doing I'm
gonna pop one last time Congressman look
in the camera and say they hacked John
pedestal's emails we know for a fact
that Putin's government did that you
can't and you know you can't and you're
hiding behind uh weasel words I I just
said that
Russians I'm not going to be specific as
well because you don't know it that's
why all right done one you don't know it
and you're alleging it without any
evidence you're ignoring the evidence
because you don't care the fact that it
that it helped uh the Republican
candidate is all you need to know that's
totally false false I just think if
you're going to make a serious
allegation about an actual country with
an actual government you don't know
talking about and you don't isn't that
interesting how the story changes but
the tactics remain the same that's
Schiff back in 2017 saying that Tucker
was carrying water for the Russians now
Flash Forward to 2023 when Tucker is
basically the loudest anti-war person
that we have now you may disagree with
that right you may think that we should
allow Ukraine to join NATO and you may
think that we should have this giant
Alliance and we have to turn back Putin
and we should risk World War III I
suppose people can make arguments about
all of those things
but what do they say about the guy
Tucker now it's the same exact thing
you're a Putin apologist you're carrying
water for the Russians when he's
basically saying how about we just don't
March towards world war three uh so it's
not just about mainstream bias towards
certain people it's about the machine
and how it wants to constantly control
the narrative so you are completely
confused about everything all the time
and then you stop trusting the people
who are approximately trying to tell you
something true and then Phil they put up
a guy like Schiff and somebody watches
it and go my God that shift's making
sense so here's another one from the
televised mental institution of MSNBC
man we are bringing out the hits today
MSNBC brought on shamed former CNN
anchor Brian stelter Brian stelter who
was once the host of reliable sources
which is I always say if they would have
just called it unreliable sources he'd
probably still have a job but he was
fired because he was a promoter of the
covid nonsense he was promote he was a
promoter of the impeachment nonsense
like kind of the worst of the worst he
gets fired from CNN he ends up teaching
journalism at Harvard
so let me just say if you're an Asian
kid and you can't get into Harvard these
days because they're still trying to
figure out ways to do affirmative action
good for you because Harvard is a
cesspool of crapulence uh it's
grappling's a word I just took that from
Mr Burns I'm not even sure if it's an
actual word but anyway so what does
MSNBC do they bring on the Fired Guy
from CNN to analyze the news media when
it comes to truth
this is the challenge that every
journalist in America is facing some
might want to avoid it might want to
pretend it's not a problem might want to
pretend they figured it out but it's an
incredibly hard problem to solve uh this
torrent of Lies directed at an
institution that's trying to get to the
truth and all right that's why we need
this kind of coverage all the time to
try to figure out the best best path to
being louder than the Liars that's our
job we are supposed to be louder than
the Liars yes Mr Potato Head and the
other guy at MSNBC they're the ones
telling you the truth the people at
MSNBC who sit there with scripts handed
to them from I don't know who who just
recite talking points from the DNC Jen
saki who worked at the administration
and then is brought on as an analyst do
you think she's going to give you an
honest assessment of what's going on so
what do they do what do they do when
being loud stelter wants to be louder
you know what I mean he's very loud at
the buffet when they run out of mac and
cheese uh but otherwise he's not that
loud but anyway he wants them to be
louder than you you pee on but when
they're not loud enough what's the other
thing they can do oh they can silence
you they can use censorship to make sure
that nobody can hear you this is a wild
video do you remember uh former New
Zealand prime minister Jacinda Arden she
was during covet she was one of the
worst of the worst will censor you stay
at home if you don't hear it from us
it's not true I mean this woman is a
true wackadoodle here she is giving a
speech over the weekend at the U.N about
free speech and why censorship is
actually necessary
this week we launched an initiative
alongside companies and non-profits to
help improve research and understanding
of how a person's online experiences are
curated by automated processes
this will also be important in
understanding more about Miss and
disinformation online a challenge that
we must As Leaders address
sadly I think it's easy to dismiss this
problem as one in the margins I can
certainly understand the desire to leave
it to someone else
as leaders were rightly concerned that
even the most light touch approaches to
disinformation could be misinterpreted
as being hostile to the values of free
speech that we value so highly
but while I cannot tell you today what
the answer is to this challenge I can
say with complete certainty that we
cannot ignore it
to do so poses an equal threat to the
Norms we all value because for every new
weapon we face
there is a new tool to overcome it
for every attempt to push the world into
chaos is a collective conviction to
bring us back to order
we have the means
we just need the collective will
does that sound scary as F or what we
have the means we just need the
collective will we have the ways to
silence the people who don't want to get
injected with stuff
we have ways to make sure certain people
disappear turn off people's bank
accounts things of that nature we just
got to get the balls to do it are you
with me man that is scary now speaking
of people who like to shut off bank
accounts of other people Justin
Trudeau's got a big problem up in Canada
right now which is that the people are
turning against him you know it was
happening during covid and it happened
during the the trucker Convoy and
everything else but now Canada has a
series of problems uh prices for
groceries have been going through the
roof there so Justin Trudeau
what does Justin Trudeau want to do well
he wants to threaten the people who are
making the food and selling the food
take a look
it's not okay
at our biggest grocery stores are making
record profits while Canadians are
struggling to put food on the table
so Minister champagne will be calling on
the heads of large Grocers to come to
Ottawa with a plan to address the rising
cost of food
and we expect to hear from them by
Thanksgiving on what their plan is to
stabilize prices
and it
and let me be very clear
if their plan doesn't provide real
relief for the middle class and people
working hard to join it then we will
take further action and we are not
ruling anything out including tax
measures
wow evil evil right we are not ruling
anything out we'll bomb all the Farms if
those Grocers don't do what we want
Justin do you think it has something to
do with your economic policies your big
government economic policies you know
what I guarantee you won't do for
everybody Justin Trudeau and the
Liberals of Canada I know you're not
going to lower taxes on everybody what
if you lowered taxes 25 across the board
so now everyone is 25 more money what if
you got out of the way so the farmers
and the Grocers would be able to do go
about their business in a more sensible
Manner and not have to deal with so much
government regulation and could grow
food more easily and sell food more
easily you think that might help
but you're not gonna do any of those
things we will do anything we have to do
we will literally nuke all the chickens
and you'll know just evil just absolute
evil but what he's really saying there
in essence is that the government will
come and take over the food chain right
he's saying if the Grocers don't do it
the way we want we've seen this in
Holland and in other countries if the
farmers don't behave a certain way the
government will come in and do
everything well guess what ladies and
gentlemen it looks like this is going to
happen in the United States too check
out this headline this is wild this is
happening in Chicago right now Chicago
mayor announces plans for government-run
grocery stores as real stores flee
shoplifters and high taxes that will
apparently be used to copy the Soviet
Union as for those shoplifters you can
guess what Chicago run store will look
like so he this is we know this is
happening now remember
what happened in Chicago Chicago had
Lori Lightfoot crazy leftist lunatic how
many people were shot in Chicago this
week let me get some numbers on that uh
Rampages of the city destroys it
whatever okay fine she does it they have
the highest gun uh the most amount of
gun laws the strictest gun policies in
the country they also have the most
shootings in the country it's so bizarre
bad guys don't listen to laws I can't
believe it right really nuts uh then
what does Chicago do they get rid of
Lori Lightfoot and they pick an even
further left nut bag and now the average
person and we've all seen the videos I
could I could do a show every day we
could do a second show where every day I
just show you people just looting stores
in LA and San Francisco and Chicago and
everywhere else right but the average
little grocer you have a little grocery
shop you can't operate in Chicago
because guys are coming in they're
shooting you they're stealing everything
et cetera et cetera do I have numbers on
the Chicago shootings this week 18
people
18 people shot in Chicago one of them
was a 16 year old girl that's that's a
little light for Chicago all right you
must have the weather must have been
nice and people were out and about
having having a good time by the way I
want to do a quick correction you guys
know I'm not above a quick correction I
said that that Jacinda Arden video the
former New Zealand prime minister I said
that that was this weekend uh that was
actually last year it still it fit the
narrative it doesn't change anything
that I said obviously but that was a
mistake on us it does happen every now
and again I have no problem uh
correcting it but all right let's keep
going with the narrative here so
government trying to control businesses
uh and people that kind of defend it and
promote the people that are doing these
things right there's still an awful lot
of people who seem to support a guy like
Justin Trudeau in Canada and who's
Judson Trudeau's butt buddy down here in
the United States it's Gavin Newsom you
know that so
Bill Maher if you're watching today I'd
like to apologize in advance but you
just dropped the ball on this one dude
and I had to cover it I had to cover it
uh here's Bill Maher this is from his
show about a week ago complaining about
Newsome right and he lives in California
he dealt with all the destruction uh
complaining about Newsome and then uh
saying that he should be president
my other question about this is why
doesn't the governor of the state of
this of the State of California which
this is a very big business in this is
entertainment we're like what cars are
to Detroit why doesn't he or were
Jawbone
you know Jawbone when presidents get
the leaders of Industries who are at
odds in a room and cracked their heads
together and you're running for
president why would you want to alienate
the money or the most important voices
oh now you've opened an interesting can
of worms Mr Gaffigan so first of all you
think God man Newsom is running for
president
I think he is uh the likely alternative
that's interesting because I remember I
like Evan a lot now I hope he runs with
resin because I think
getting to the National stage would help
with the one thing I ever have trouble
with him about which is sometimes he's
way too
Google
woke left you know the
California well she was it was the
mayor of San Francisco right yeah
you know
you're making me do you're making me do
this what are you talking about Gavin
Newsom was the mayor of San Francisco
San Francisco is a third world country
there are drugs and crime everywhere you
guys know it we could have showed you
some b-roll of anything over the weekend
of just zombie apocalypse Gavin do some
style in San Francisco he then exported
that to California a million people have
left California in the last three years
uh Los Angeles San Francisco all the big
cities crumbling there's a massive
problem related to the cities and the
northern part of California where they
have the actual resources the farms and
the water there's a fight about that
none of it makes any sense there's you
know obviously crime and homeless is
like the easy part but there's just like
an actual cultural rot and everything
else I like Gavin and I hope he runs for
president
I I will keep trying with you Bill but
what is going on here what yeah maybe
you guys see see the weakness there that
I'm trying to just push him over the
edge on and I I just I'll keep trying
but his one criticism is that he's too
woke I mean he's literally about to sign
a bill that will allow the state to take
away parent uh children from parents
because they don't affirm which they
actually by a firm they mean unaffirm
their child's uh gender it's it's really
just nuts but okay this is this is the
reason I wanted to show you that clip
because because then Bill does something
good and gets it on something else uh
what bill was referencing at the top of
that was the writer strike that's
happening in Hollywood now nobody really
cares about the writer strike the late
night shows aren't on right now there's
very little production happening in
Hollywood the writers are on strike now
you can argue maybe they deserve more
money maybe they don't but what's
interesting is everyone's getting their
entertainment elsewhere and I don't see
anyone caring about it and bill has
decided to bring back real time the
other late night shows uh which are all
you know they've all got staffs of like
20 30 people easily on the writing staff
alone most of them they have staffs in
the hundred in terms of Lighting and
Sound and the rest of it and what's
below the line and everything else
um but Bill is bringing real time back
so on one hand he's like I'm sort of
four unions all right I love Gavin I
love government and all this stuff and
then on the other hand he's like but you
know I want to get back to work and I
think he's right about it here here's
his tweet about coming back he said real
time is coming back unfortunately Sans
writers or writing it has been five
months and it's time to bring people
back to work the writers have important
issues that I sympathize with and I hope
they are addressed to their satisfaction
but they are not the only people with
issues problems and concerns despite
some assistance from me much of the
staff is struggling mightily we all were
hopeful this would come to an end after
Labor Day but the day has come and gone
and there still seems to be nothing
happening I love my writers I'm one of
them but I'm not prepared to lose an
entire year and see so many people below
the line suffer so much I will honor the
spirit of the strike by not doing a
monologue desk piece new rules or
editorial the written pieces that I'm so
proud of on real time and I'll say it up
front to the audience the show I will be
doing without my writers will not be as
good as our normal show full stop but
the heart of the show is an off-the-cuff
panel discussion that aims to cut
through the and predictable
partisanship and that will continue the
show will not disappoint okay fine now I
think it's good and I think the writers
overplayed their hand right people just
aren't clamoring for them to come back
so on one hand he's getting it he's
getting it about unions what unions do
the writers Union in essence is going to
cause an awful lot of writers to never
get back to work and it's also going to
cause when he talks about the below the
line people it's the sound people the
guy who puts the mic on the makeup
people why should none of them be
getting paid because the writers are
pissed right that's the that's the
struggle of oh we're going to be in a
union and we're going to do what's just
best for us we don't give a about
anybody else well bill has just kind of
had enough of it so again he gets some
things right gets other things wrong is
what it is another host I didn't even
know she had a talk show but apparently
Drew Barry remember actress Drew Barry
she had she was in E.T wasn't she an ET
I don't know what else she was in Gray
Gardens she was in E.T a couple things
over the years she was in a couple
movies with Adam Sandler anyway she had
or she has a talk show now the talk show
went off because the writers were gone
and then she announced that she was
going to come back because it's kind of
like Bill it's like should I take a year
off I have other people that work for me
you know not everybody can just survive
forever so she announces the show is
coming back
the cancel machine comes for her that
everybody hates her she's evil so what
does she do webcam video crying please
I deeply apologize to writers
I deeply apologize to unions
I deeply apologize
I wanted to own a decision so that it
wasn't a PR
atted situation and I would just take
full responsibility for my actions
I know there's just
nothing I can do that will make this
okay for those that is not okay with
this is bigger than me and there are
other people's jobs on the line
I want to just put one foot in front of
the other and make a show that's there
for people regardless of anything else
that's
all right so first off I have to issue
with second correction her name is Drew
Barrymore not Drew Barry I think I was
getting her confused with Drew Carey
which she's kind of morphing into him
anyway if you see how insane this is she
did what she thought was right right she
did what she thought was right for
herself for the other people on her
shows their fan you know the other
people that work on her show who aren't
just writers to all these other people
who want to go back to work but then I
have to deeply apologize it's one thing
to say I deeply apologize to the writers
right like that's one thing to say if
you're the if you're the talent on the
show that's what they call them the
talent you're the front-facing person I
do apologize I deeply apologize to the
unions that sounds that sounds like the
most sellout I deeply apologize to the
unions there are there are vending
machines in those Union offices and
somebody's got to eat the kitkats like
it just sounds like such a freaking
sellout
yeah but all right lady they're gonna
hate you no matter what you do so oh so
anyway long story short so now her
Show's back off so the show was on then
it was off she did what she thought was
right now she's backtracking on the
whole thing her Show's off again okay so
what is the point of showing you all
this and how does this connect to
everything else these people there is a
set of people that just want to be liked
more than anything else they want to be
liked by all sides and they want to be
at every dinner and never really take a
position on anything so that they can be
liked and liked and liked and liked
so now let's talk about former president
Donald Trump Donald Trump went on and
I've been look I've been very critical
of Donald Trump lately I am getting a
ton of hate for it uh and I'm just
going to do what I think is right I
really am I'm going to continue doing
what I think is right you know I have
seen some well I'll tell you that part
in just a second let's go to a video so
Donald Trump went on Meet the Press on
Sunday now you might have noticed that
I'll Meet the Press they have a new host
uh this past weekend because last week
as I told you was uh what's his name
Chuck Todd's last week he took Meet the
Press in his 10 years of Meet the Press
he took it from number one Sunday
morning talk show he had left it in last
shape in the last in the ratings okay
they get a new host on Meet the Press
and when I tell you that Donald Trump is
part of the machine this is exactly what
I mean who do they get as their first
guest Donald Trump because Trump
inflates the machine that he's
constantly trying to tell you how bad is
it's fake News NBC and CNN and New York
Times what he'll give Insider access to
Maggie hamberman at the New York Times
he'll be the first guest on the newly
revamped Meet the Press so that they can
get good ratings while he can tell you
he hates them but anyway one clip in
particular went viral the I don't even
know her name what's the new host's name
does anyone even know
some chick she's got a job good for her
she probably won't have it very long she
asked uh former president Trump on his
uh feelings about abortion and as you
know Ron DeSantis is doing the heartbeat
bill here in Florida six weeks a couple
other states have done that uh and they
talked about abortion Supreme Court et
cetera check out this answer
I want to give voters who are going to
be weighing in on this election yeah a
very clear sense I think they're all
going to like me I think both sides are
going to like me let me let me have to
happen is you're going to have to get
this question you're asking me a
question what's going to happen is
you're going to come up with a number of
weeks or months you're going to come up
with a number that's going to make
people happy because 92 percent of the
Democrats don't want to see abortion
after a certain period of time if
Federal ban landed on your desk if you
were re-elected would you sign it at 15.
are you talking about a complete ban a
ban at 15 weeks people people are
starting to think of 15 weeks that seems
to be a number that people are talking
about right now would you sign that I
would I would sit down with both sides
and I'd negotiate something and we'll
end up with peace in that issue for the
first time in 52 years I'm not going to
say I would or I wouldn't I mean to
Sanctus is willing to sign a five-week
and six week did you support that you
think that I think what he did is a
terrible thing and a terrible mistake
there's so much there my pen is going to
run out of ink okay first off I'm
framing this around
the certain set of people that want to
be like no matter what listen to
everything he said there they're going
to like me on both sides I'm going to
come up with a number that both sides
will like on abortion the thing that
drives people drives the wedge more than
anything else Donald Trump now after all
of these years suddenly now he will come
down Jesus like and solve the abortion
thing so that everyone will like him
because that's what he cares about more
than anything else as many people like
him as possible not what's morally right
or what's legally right or
constitutionally right or anything like
that there's so much nonsense there so
first off that he just frames it around
that most people that they'll all like
me on this thing right now you also have
to imagine that the question in and of
itself is stupid because the reversal of
Roe v Wade kicked it back to the States
now I will give credit to Trump he got
justices on the court if you believe in
the Constitution and that states rights
matter well then Roe v Wade regardless
of your feeling about abortion was not
just because there obviously was no
constitutional right to an abortion
right it's not in it's not something
that's in the Constitution so things
that are not in the Constitution get
kicked back to the state so Trump
deserves credit for the composition of
the court that did the right thing but
now when he's saying and I will come up
with something that everybody will like
and blah blah blah it's like first off
it's up to the States now it's up to the
states it's not up to the president so
the idea that we're always talking about
this at a national level is also is
because the people in the media like her
name what's her name Kristen Welker or
something it's because it's because
she's misguided and Confused obviously
or or intentionally obtuse and that
Trump is even saying that like it will
not be up to the president what abortion
will be it will be up to the States but
the line that's really getting people
right now is that he said that what Ron
de Sanctus and the fact that he calls
him to Sanctus and that that she doesn't
immediately say why doesn't she just say
and every interviewer going forward I
would include Megan in this and Megan
did an absolutely spectacular job last
week with Trump every time he said why
do you call him that why do we have
nicknames for anybody else is it because
you're in bed with uh vivekan we all
kind of know it and you know nobody else
has a chance
but you keep calling him a name and why
do you talk about him so much because
you know he's the one that can get you
right you do know that he's actually on
the ground going all 99 to Santa's I'm
talking about going to all 99 counties
in Iowa right but but we've already we
expect so little out of trump that he
the scientists sanctimonious and nobody
even says anything right like are we do
we want to be third graders forever or
do we want to be adults
I know what I want to be but what do you
want to be that's really the question
here
um but but that he calls the heartbeat
Bill terrible is really interesting
because look I personally I've written
about this I've discussed it many times
I've debated it with Ben Shapiro
with Dennis Prager personally Florida
had a 15-week ban right that's that's a
little more than three months uh it's
before the fetus can feel pain and in a
society where we're going to have a
pluralistic set of views and and
philosophies and religions and all of
those things
it was a compromise Ron DeSantis did not
lie he had always said he was pro-life
and he has a super majority here and he
decided to push forward with this
six-week heart uh heartbeat thing now
you may be for it or against it but but
Trump as the pro-life guy the the the
base loves he's the most pro-life
president ever right like he's probably
paid some women for abortions but okay
put that aside even for a second
um he's he's supposed to be Mr pro-life
and he calls it terrible I it was the
word terrible that I saw that really
pissed off people that the that banning
abortion at the heartbeat that that
somehow is terrible is an odd thing now
I'm not even for it right this is the I
think the one issue that I have a real
difference with this hair design I was
okay with our 15-week thing here in
Florida to me 15 week is what every
every moderate Democrat of 20 years ago
would have said about three months about
15 weeks is the right thing right some
people would have said 20 at 20 they
they know that the fetus can feel pain
and now that now that science is
actually advancing in this type of stuff
they're learning it's a little bit
earlier and earlier the point is
nobody's
the only absolute position you can have
on this is the second the sperm meets
the egg when no woman knows she's
pregnant that at that point she cannot
have an abortion most people don't feel
that and I think Trump in some ways is
campaigning for the general more than
he's campaigning for the Republican
nomination he's also afraid of stepping
on stage with DeSantis so that kind of
proves that right there
but this sort of thing that at the end
what's your everyone will love me I will
say the thing that everyone will love is
it true is it based on anything or
anything else
this is a real problem I bring this up
because everyone including Trump and I
can probably suffer from it from some
extent and and I am seeing so many
people right now that are completely
captured by their own audiences right
now
after the horrible answer that Trump
gave to Megan Kelly when he couldn't say
whether a man can turn into a woman he
couldn't just immediately say no he had
to stammer through it right this thing
that this the heartbeat bill is terrible
these answers the the inability to say I
screwed up with fauci I screwed up with
lockdowns like all of that I deserve
more credit with covid everyone is
captured by Their audience and the
second you're captured without everyone
many people are captured by the audience
and it can happen to anyone I am trying
to fight that very hard by not being
captured by my audience so I have a lot
of you pissed at me because of my
feelings about Trump right now but I'm
talking now to the to the conservative
set of people who are supposed to be the
Deep truth tellers and they're gonna
call balls and Strikes and all that
stuff why is it nobody's playing the
clips of trump on Megyn Kelly why is it
that everyone went silent on that little
piece that we just showed you right
there about the heartbeat bill because
they are afraid that if they say
anything against Trump or the base as
Charlie Kirk told me if they say
anything against it they will be
destroyed
I just will not play that game and it
might cost me clicks and Views and money
and everything else but I'm going to do
what I think is right but audience
capture I think Trump is suffering from
it I think the pundits are suffering
from it and I can see why it's an easy
trapdoor that any of us could get caught
in
so what is the Segway that brings us
back to the beginning
the segue is the addition
be a dissident like Russell Brand be an
ex-hollywood Rebel be someone who fights
the system be someone who maybe had a
messy past that is living an honest
truthful today
and if you do that I just think over
time we can correct this ship don't be
someone that never can say that they
screwed up in the case of Donald Trump
don't be someone that can never have a
Maya culpa or show some kind of
Contrition don't be someone that just
endlessly gives to the machine
who cares if everyone doesn't love you
you guys aren't going to believe this
there are some people that don't like me
they're out there okay
they don't like me it's okay it really
is okay truth should matter more truth
should matter more
and how will the system treat you just
one or two more for you this is a tweet
from the telegraph how will the system
treat you if you if you say those scary
things this is from the telegraph
yesterday Russell Brand climbed the
Hollywood ladder while railing against
the capitalist elite
all he's after is whatever serves his
ego and wallet how bizarre that they're
writing that headline just as all of the
other stuff is coming do you think it's
coordinated do you think they've been
working on this piece for a long time to
take him out do you think do you think
guys can you see it one more Russell
Brand couple years ago go provide
alternative narratives and not only
provide the narratives invite you to
create the narratives with us because
you know one thing I know I don't know
what's best I've made a lot of mistakes
I've been wrong many times but I'm
beginning to think I'm right about this
the mainstream media is not your friend
the culture is not your friend the
government is not your friend big
business is not your friend
all right look so we're going to be in a
time where they can come after everybody
I get it they could come after me so
it's time I had a mayakopa of my own
in third grade this is totally true guys
in third grade
I was into He-Man He-Man was huge back
then around 1984 or something like that
uh Skeletor obviously was the main guy
going after He-Man and I had Skeletor
but I lost his staff we find out what
the name of skeletor's staff was it had
like a little like a horror like a horn
or a Ram's Head on it I think it had a
name his staff lost his staff it came
with the staff
uh one day I went to my friend Chad Chad
W you know who you are I went to Chad's
house and Chad had it was called the
Havoc staff thank you
Chad had the Havoc staff
and Chad didn't really care about He-Man
he was into sports a little bit earlier
than I was I was still doing my He-Man
GI Joe Transformers thing and I uh
I stole the staff
I stole the Havoc staff from Chad Chad W
You Know Who You Are
we live two blocks away he used to ride
your bike to my house all the time and I
just want to get ahead of this thing
because I know they're coming for me
I apologize
and uh you know Chad if there's ever
anything I can do for you we're going to
send this clip to you if you ever need
help a little cash get out of a bind
you want me to promote so I don't know
what you're doing I don't know where you
live I don't know what's going on with
you we lost touch I hope you're doing
all right Chad guys it's me Monday over
at the Reuben report locals Community
here's the one that I put up
when you buy your John fetterman costume
from wish look at all of the John
fettermans that you can be by the way I
want to cover this story tomorrow we
didn't even get to it today but uh Chuck
Schumer has now put new rules in at the
house where they don't have to dress any
particular way anymore men used to have
to dress basically in suits and ties uh
and women had to be in I think they
called it business business casual
attire or something like that they are
throwing all the rules out and it's like
we are going to have no standards
anymore it's gonna we're gonna literally
have people dressing up as clowns and
trans robots and everything else I don't
mean Transformers like trans like you
get it you get it anyway if you want to
join us for the post game show it's
coming up right now at
reubenreport.locals.com oh and by the
way over the weekend we put up an
interview with a lady by the name of
Sonia Shaw she is the woman we played a
clip of her last week in Chino
California she's the head of the school
board there who they were fighting
to kick out this gender nonsense from uh
their their classrooms in Chino
California because there are a couple
sane people in Cali remaining and the
state superintendent uh from Sacramento
came on down to try to shut her down she
kicked them out it's a whole brujah
Avenue in Chino right now you can check
that out on Rumble and on locals of
course and YouTube post game show in
just a second we leave you with Nancy
Pelosi who's
running again 847 years old she just
wants to save the children
hello it's Nancy
thank you for giving me the privilege to
represent our city and our San Francisco
values in the Congress and amplifying
the voice of the big dark money in
politics that is my why why I am in
Congress for the big dark money this is
my story and this is my song as you hear
me say when you're in the arena you have
to be able to punch the children
and that is why I am running for
reelection to Congress and respectfully
seek your support I would be greatly
honored by it and grateful for it thank
you so much
[Music]